no reaction in fact he didn't even speak
to confirm his name when asked at the
beginning apologies we're going to drop
out of that and take you to secure
stamina
the police have now completed their
investigation and found that there is no
case to answer
people said to me
i was taking a risk by saying i would
step down if i was fined
but it was never about that
for me
it was a matter of principle
it shouldn't be controversial
to say that those who make the law
can't break the law
but we have to set the bar far higher
than that
our country is stuck
in a dangerous rut
everywhere you look
things are broken
and nothing gets fixed
people say to me when they look at those
running the country
they see a group of people
totally detached from reality
whose words mean nothing
and who put their own interests first
who could blame them
for concluding that politics doesn't
matter
and doesn't work
this is not just about boris johnson
this feeling that politics has failed
hasn't emerged in the last few months
it's been bubbling away for years
and people have completely lost faith
that this can be changed
that politics can be a force for good
the reason i made the promise that i did
was to change their mind
because when politics is done well
when people can have faith that
politicians words mean something
when the power of government sits in the
hands of those determined to serve the
country
like when labour created the nhs
when we introduced the equal pay act
and when we brought people together to
deliver peace in northern ireland
politics
can change lives
and that is what i will do
as prime minister
it's vital
that we reboot our economy
re-energize our communities
revitalize our public services
and give britain the fresh start it
needs
in the coming days i'll set out more
about how a reforming labor government
will achieve just that
it's no small project
and i know
i have to convince you
to put your trust in me
and believe that together we can build a
better country
i won't get everything right
i'm certainly not perfect
and i will make mistakes along the way
but what you will always get from me
is someone who believes honesty and
integrity matter
someone who will work every day
for the good of the country
and someone who will not betray the
faith
that you place in me
thank you
thank you very much i think we're going
to go to
questions first i've got a list which
i'll work to and hope to get it right
chris i think we've got you first thank
you chris mason bbc news sakia whilst
you must be relieved isn't this the week
that your job has actually gotten much
harder with the resignation of boris
johnson the man you've defined yourself
against
no not in the slightest the contrast
between
the tory party which is tearing itself
apart with a cast list of wannabe
leaders who've all propped up this prime
minister for months and months and
months knowing he's unfit for office
contrast that to the labour party uh
we're united we want to press on with a
plan for britain um and the change we
want is more fundamental and a change at
the top of the conservative party so um
this is a very good week for the labour
party and my challenge to the taurus is
not who's your next leader going to be
but give us the change we really need
let's have a general election let's have
a change of government a fresh start for
our country
uh sam
um
you're pushing them kiss tommy you're
pushing for a vote of no confidence next
week yeah if you win there'll be an
election do you think the answer to the
chaos and instability at the moment is a
general election
yes we've been
stuck in the middle of a cost of living
crisis with a cub with government that
can't deliver well the prime minister's
not fit to be prime minister the
conclusion at last of the parliamentary
conservative party
propped up by people all around him
who've known for months that he couldn't
deliver of course we need change
fundamental change it's not just about
the last few months either we've had 12
years of stagnation 12 years of low
growth so britain deserves that fresh
start
that can only come with a change of
government
anushka
thank you um sorry i've got two
questions ah we're back
get to question three before we do the
double up oh yeah okay um you see this
is a good result but conservative mps
are telling me they see it as a good
result too because they think you're
more beatable than some of your labour
colleagues what do you say to that and
as you said durham police say there is
no case to answer so do you think they
bowed to political pressure in launching
this investigation well look on the um
position of where we're at as a lab
party i had no end of people telling me
in 2020 when i took over the labour
party that was impossible to get from
where we'd landed in 2019 to the
prospect of a labour government i didn't
believe it
we've pressed on we've got really good
local election results and a fantastic
swing in wakefield so i block out the
noise we plow on uh if there's a general
election this government will fall and
we've got a plan for the country we want
that fresh start um and i'm not going to
listen to the noises off that for two
years have been telling me this is
impossible we're proving it's possible
what's what's happened now is it's not
just hope of a labour government it's a
belief
in a labour government as for the police
look
i spent five years as director of public
prosecutions working with all the police
forces across the whole country and
there were no end of politicians who
tried to tell the police what to do i'm
not going to do that
they make their decisions and i respect
whatever decisions they've come to here
they come to a clear conclusion that
there was no case to answer i was always
confident that the rules weren't broken
they'd come to a very very clear
conclusion
paul
secure
in wakefield and lots of other places in
the country
people have been saying to us not i
really want to vote for kierstarma but i
don't like boris johnson he's gone now
isn't a new leader actually bad for you
look in wakefield what we saw were
labour voters coming back to labour
something people told me wouldn't happen
um we saw the same in the local
elections across the whole of the
country um and so i'm not going to
listen to these noises off we've come a
huge way
in two years we're ready now for a
general election um and rather than
noises off if they're so confident well
let's have that general election let's
get on with it let's have the fresh
start that we need for our country so
let them put their money where their
mouth is if they really think that call
a general election
might be a general election well look i
don't mind when the general election is
we'll be ready for it
andy
thank you andy bell five news
aren't you playing politics with this
call for a vote of no confidence because
if this was a situation that was
reversed and it was a labor
prime minister who'd stepped down as
leader of the labour party exactly the
same thing would be playing through this
is just your way of trying to exploit
this situation no look there's a world
of difference between this situation and
previous situations where a leader has
stepped down if you take theresa may for
example
there was a policy dispute within her
party
that in the end led to her resignation
but she stayed on
this prime minister boris johnson has
been brought down on the issue of trust
and integrity because his front bench
didn't believe that when they were going
out to do media rounds they were being
told the truth
that is a million miles from a policy
dispute you can't you can't resign
saying the prime minister doesn't tell
the truth he's got no integrity he keeps
sending me out to say things which
aren't true
but i'll now serve him for two months
because i think miraculously in the next
two months that's all going to change it
just doesn't make sense i think it's
materially different to other situations
i understand why theresa may stayed on
this prime minister is desperately
clinging on he should go and should go
straight away in my view
uh dominic p.a
can you hear me yeah i can now yeah the
um government has like
signaled that it can continue with that
controversial policies such as the
rwanda asylum scheme the northern
ireland protocol bill
what would you say to that do you think
there should just be a freeze on
legislation or on policy for the next
few months i think well
my preferred option and the right option
is the prime minister should go go
straight away um and i think
that there's plenty of people in the
conservative party who agree with me on
that he shouldn't be desperately
clinging on when he has had to leave
office because of his disgraceful
conduct um and that's why i say uh the
tory party should remove him um and if
they don't we will step up in the
national interest and bring a vote of no
confidence that's what i think should
happen
i think we've got mason from the
telegraph
um
in terms of no confidence start next
week um how sure are you that any
conservatives will actually support that
has there been any private conversations
between yourself your team with tory mps
who said actually if you do
bring that confidence vote we will
support it because we want the prime
minister gone well
let me be clear i think the duty is on
the conservative party to do the right
thing and obviously there are meetings
early next week with the 22 committee so
it's for them to do the right thing if
they don't we'll step up with a vote of
no confidence there are plenty i mean
you've seen what's happened this week
there are plenty of conservatives who
said they do not have faith in the prime
minister mass resignations more
resignations in one day for a prime
minister i think than ever in the
history of our country um
the idea that they will then all troop
to say now a few days later we do have
faith in him again um beggar's belief
but actually the duties on the
conservative party they know that this
prime minister is being removed um
because he's not fit for office rather
than a policy disagreement so they know
that he's got to go and he shouldn't be
clinging on
do we have harriet from the mail
no
do we have anyone else from mail i don't
know
no
um peter from the guardian
hi hi um
okay it sounded like from the mini
speech you did at the start that you're
going to have a kind of policy push
coming on in the kind of next few weeks
and months but there's some critics who
say you should have set out what you
stand for a bit earlier in your kind of
time period
and and thus far you seem to be in
voters minds just contrasting yourself
mainly it's not being boris johnson as
being an honest person who do the right
thing do you agree that
it's perhaps overdue for you to set out
exactly what a labor government would do
well peter we've set out
on a number of occasions what we see to
be the central
most important political argument which
is how do we grow the economy the root
cause of so much of what we're going
through at the moment is the fact that
we've had a stagnant economy for 12
years with low growth we've set that out
we've identified it we've set out the
relationship we will have with business
to
resolve it we've said how we will invest
how we will have a new skills agenda and
how
we will might make buy and sell more in
britain so we actually have said a lot
about the core political arguments
there'll be more coming from me in the
coming weeks of course um and over the
summer
but we have set that out we need to
repeat it over and over again but i
think that how we grow the economy is
the single most important issue that
faces this country uh and i want the
next election to be about that issue on
which we've already said a lot and we
will say a lot more
um have we got jack from the sun
jack
thanks akia um you've made clear today
that you think that the tories are not
fit to govern so isn't the truth that in
an election you would do a coalition
with the liberal democrats and the
scottish national party and if not will
you rule it out now i will absolutely
rule it out let me take the snp first
there will be no deal going into a
general election and no deal coming out
of a general election and that's not
just about a numbers game as far as i'm
concerned i want to be prime minister
for the whole of the united kingdom
i want to labor government for the whole
of the united kingdom there is no basis
no basis for an alliance with a party
who wants to break up the united kingdom
i want to grow the economy there's no
basis
for an alliance with the party that
thinks the answer to growing the economy
is to put a border between england and
scotland so it's not just a numbers game
it's an in-principle position there is
no basis for an alliance under a kia
starman government between labor and the
snp full stop
so far as lib dems are concerned we are
we want a labor majority we want to
deliver on our mission
and that is what we are going to do we
are fighting for a majority labor
government to deliver our mission thank
you jack
um i don't have a name for anyone from
the time so do we have anyone
or the mirror
or the express no
in which case thank you all very much
well